the cast of spider-man no way home was
out in full force on monday december
13th for the movie's premiere in los
angeles and as usual all eyes were on
tom holland and zendaya but there was
also another no way home star who was
managing to turn heads on social media
though for very different reasons dr
strange actor benedict cumberbatch
surprisingly became the talk of twitter
monday night following his stroll down
the no way home red carpet cumberbatch's
master of the mystic arts embarks on a
multiversal journey with holland's peter
parker in the newest mcu film which hit
theaters nationwide on december 17th
coming off the death of tony stark
cumberbatch's stranger set to serve as a
new on-screen mentor of swords to
holland's parker in their way home with
that in mind it seems only right that he
start dressing like downey jr's fallen
avenger at least when cumberbatch showed
up on monday to the la premiere of no
way home the infinity war and end game
star was sporting a different but all
too familiar look that had many fans
feeling a little you guessed it strange
we know we've seen this style of glasses
at some point in the past but can you
recognize where you've seen them in the
history of the marvel cinematic universe
before for the spider-man no way home
premiere benedict cumberbatch decided to
don a stylish black suit and some orange
tinted shades that looks like they've
been pulled straight out of tony stark's
closet indeed the cumber batches the
glasses are a different color but they
also undeniably look a great deal like
the set of spectacles worn by iron man
in the last two avengers films those
glasses were eventually inherited by
peter parker in spider-man far from home
but cumberbatch would seem to have
gotten his hands on a slightly different
set marvel fans predictably took to
social media to share their reactions to
the no way home stars tony stark's ask
luck one twitter user joked i know they
said strange would act as the iron man
of this next chapter in the mcu but he
looks like he's doing tony stark cosplay
another posted like i'm sorry are you
doctor strange or tony stark laughing
myself identity crisis and another fan
tweeted everyone just wants to rock that
rdj look a video posted online by marvel
shows cumberbatch fielding questions
from reporters and looking suave at the
no way home premiere while many people
poked fun at his look too some fans
really liked it in spider-man far from
home stark's glasses take on the biggest
plus importance of any set of glasses in
film since the 2004 release of national
treasure in which benjamin franklin's
glasses helped reveal the secret
location of a centuries-old treasure
worth millions of dollars peter is
initially happy to have something to
remember his fallen mentor by but is
also completely ignorant of the power of
the glasses the glasses are inhabited by
an ai known as edith which grants him
complete control over the various
weapons system of stark industries in an
amusing scene on the bus peter
discreetly uses the glasses in an
attempt to hack her classmate's cell
phone to delete a picture of himself
however in the process of testing out
the glasses peter nearly winds up
killing everyone on the bus thankfully
his spidey sense alerts him to the
danger and he is able to avert the
crisis with none of his classmates any
wiser later the glasses become even more
important when peter unwittingly hands
him over to one of his greatest enemies
however cumberbatch's sunglasses
probably have an even more important
real life application cumberbatch told
enemy in a recent interview i'm not
trying to be bono i have eye problems in
my family so you can't be too careful
though cumberbatch sported a blue tinted
pair of sunglasses during its interview
with nme we have to wonder if his tony
starkish glasses are a second
prescription that he found especially
appropriate for the night given
stranger's new role in the mcu as a
mentor to peter spider-man no way home
is in theaters now
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
no way home are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one